we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p call anytime even if it's 4
a.m. and many of you seem to like to
call it 4 a.m. and that's great that's
okay you can call to 192 david p and
leave us a voicemail number we have two
voicemails for you today
let's go with the first one is this our
Australian friend who loves the show
hey David Technic Charlie has a calendar
collect content please just please keep
putting your content up and making it
just awesome you are what awesome is
right Roy very nice words from Israeli
to assume that he's Australian well his
we heard even though we get we have
caller ID okay and if he's not
Australian he is both spoofing an
Australian number and accent so I
believe that this is an Australian
individual think we'll take him at his
word yeah I believe so and then one more
quick little voicemail for you this one
really needs no introduction can you
smell what The Rock is cooking
interesting yeah I would not think to
call a show and in very calm delivery
today can you smell what The Rock is
cooking that delivery is not right if
the delivery strikes me as it's being
underplayed but anyway this is basically
every morning for me I listen to about a
hundred of these each day it should hire
someone full-time just to go through the
voicemail just to review them to give
him a full thorough overview on the
bonus show today a Democratic governor
is no more I don't mean he died I mean
he is now a Republican governor we will
also talk about a bizarre sea creature
attack that left a 16 year old legs in
rough shape let me put it that way we
will also tell you the results of a very
very exciting sausage survey in Canada
which littles sought to determine are
the meats listed on sausage packaging
actually the meats contained in the
sausages hint very often they are not I
hope we can go to the meat of the issue
here we're going to get to the core of
it yeah okay vegan meat jokes from
producer Pat today great bonus show
today
david pakman.com slash membership sign
up get instant access coupon code I
voted 17 is available to you if you like